public sénat en partenariat avec la fp
les échos radio classique présente
jean pierre raffarin est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir monsieur
raffarin
bonsoir monsieur bonsoir à tous et merci
d'être avec nous vous inaugurez cette
nouvelle émission ce nouveau rendez-vous
de public sénat avec nos nouveaux
partenaires radio classique et les échos
et toujours avec la fp donc on se
retrouvera désormais chaque mardi en
direct à 18h30 et pour 45 minutes trois
grandes parties et veut pour 6,3 grande
partie lors de l'épreuve de vérité à
chaque fois une grande question monsieur
raffarin la première faut-il adapter
l'état de droit à la menace terroriste
jean-francis pécresse de radio classique
et des échos vous posera la question
dans un instant la deuxième question
alain juppé que vous soutenez
tiendra-t-il la distance face à nicolas
sarkozy oui suite répondez vous tout de
suite mais tout meilleurs c'est nadège
pull jacques de l'agencé france presse
qui vous poseraient la question enfin la
troisième adressée au président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense est ce que l'armée française
est à bout de souffle les hauts gradés
disent que vraiment ils n'ont plus les
moyens de mener les guerres qu'on leur
demande
michaël szames s2 public sénat sera là
tout à l'heure mais d'abord jean pierre
raffarin
cette première question d'actualité
francs françois hollande et manuel valls
affirme encore aujourd'hui assez
fortement contre la direction d'alstom
que le site de belfort vivra est-ce que
vous soutenez l'exécutif dans son bras
de fer avec ce groupe industriel
j'ai sauvé alstom en 2003 2004 quand
c'est est en grande difficulté
je suis pour qu'on défende cette
entreprise et son implantation à belfort
je soutiens évidemment le gouvernement
dans son bras de fer mais le
gouvernement agit bien tardivement
je rappelle que le gouvernement a est au
capital d'alstom qu'il avait le temps de
voir venir et que d'autre part nous
payons là l'échec de la politique
ferroviaire du gouvernement qui supprime
en l'écotaxe s'est contraint à ne plus
avoir les financements pour permettre un
aménagement du territoire national qui
donne offert aux rails tout simple alors
vous sanctionnez doublement le
gouvernement est ce qu'il ya eu selon
vous
et faïences et vacances du gouvernement
qu'est ce que vous nous dites
effectivement qu'il avait tout bien
passionnant mais bien de vacances
défaillance quand je vois que les élus
j'entendrai cédric perrin sénateur de
belfort à l'instant quand je vois que
les élus sont informés aussi tardivement
et que l'état est actionnaire à 20% mais
qu'a fait l'état dans tout cela
et là se pose la question de monsieur
macron depuis elle a négligé ces
dossiers vous de ce dossier on le voit
venir ça ne se prend pas comme ça une
décision de cette nature
et quand on a supprimé les contacts on a
supprimé les investissements des régions
en matière ferroviaire
on a supprimé les modernisations en
grande partie de la sncf et donc en ne
donnant pas les moyens aux trains
notamment parce qu'on n'a pas fait
l'écotaxe on se trouve dans la situation
aujourd'hui de déficit donc les
responsabilités sur ce dossier sont
l'autre alors aujourd'hui on soutient le
bras de fer mais on se dit quand même on
pense quand même que les choses auraient
pu être traités autres mais vous pensez
que l'on peut même si vous rappelez
effectivement que la sncf- exemple
aujourd'hui n'a pas les moyens est ce
que vous pensez néanmoins qu'on peut
sauver le site de belfort et bien sûr on
peut on peut se trouver le manque de
belfort simplement en donnant aux rails
français la place qui doit avoir c'est à
dire en faisant en sorte que la commande
publique sert notre industrie et quand
j'entends dire que on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui comment des français je
voudrais savoir comment font les autres
pour que ce soit d'une manière générale
les pays qui sont des pays très
partenaires de la france qui eux
prennent les commandes dans leur propre
industrie et que nous on pourrait pas
aller les français nous ramène justement
la question de la productivité de la
rentabilité des sites français
jean-pierre of fame et quand on est au
capital depuis aussi longtemps que les
états sur alstom
tout ceci s'anticipe il ya une
responsabilité d'actionnaire de l'état
dans cette affaire
voilà qui est dit à leur première grande
partie thématique mettant de l'épreuve
de vérité jean pierre raffarin et donc
nous accueillons jean-francis pécresse
de radio classique et des échos je vous
le rappelle nos nouveaux partenaires
première question est ce que vous êtes
de ceux qui pensent qu'il faut tordre un
peu notre notre état de droit pour
l'adapter aux risques terroristes
je crois qu'il faut pas tordre l'état de
droit l'état de droit c'est là où se
puise l'autorité j'aime bien quand il ya
les discours de fermeté quand on prend
des postures et qu'est ce que c'est que
l'autorité
l'autorité c'est de la force qui
s'appuie sur le droit il faut faire
respecter les règles celui qui a de
l'autorité c'est celui qui fait
respecter les règles y compris à soi
même donc l'état de droit est quelque
chose qu'on ne doit pas bousculés à
chaque instant par exemple on nous a dit
pendant quinze jours qu'il fallait
changer la constitution pour le burqini
aujourd'hui plus personne ne parle du
burkina donc si on change les choses
comme ça
systématiquement en fonction de
l'actualité on a un désordre du droit
qui nuit à la l'autorit là c'est plus
que c'est plus l'actualité que jean
pierre raffarin c'est la menace
terroriste comme l'europe oui mais une
situation non mais non mais c'est pour
vous montrer le bureau d'état de droit
on aurait fait un congrès pour réformer
il ya quinze jours la constitution pour
le burqini donc moi je ne suis pas pour
que tous les quinze jours on est un état
de droit déstabilise qu'il faille de
temps en temps réformer je pense que
pour ce qui est par exemple des fiches s
et qu' on puisse mettre hors d'état de
nuire un certain nombre de gens il faut
dans le cas des fiches s identifier ceux
qui ont vraiment commis des délits et
des crimes donc qu'il puisse y avoir des
réflexions juridique sur ce sujet là
pour nous donner le moyen juridique de
donner le moyen au juge état de droit
d'avoir la possibilité de mettre hors
d'état de nuire des personnes c'est tout
à fait faux sang qu'elle forme sous la
forme d'une rétention administrative
sous le contrôle du juge
au préalable est ce que sur ce sujet là
vous êtes en phase avec ce que sarkozy
propose par exemple aux côtés moi je
connais bien les propositions d'alain
juppé je ne regarde pas tous les matins
ce que dit sarkozy c'est très bien mais
il a été aux responsabilités j'ai vu ce
qu'il a fait sur ces sujets donc je
regarde ce qu'il faut faire maintenant
de nouveau et c'est ce que propose à la
gc sous l'autorité du juge un état de
droit c'est l'autorité du juge mais il
faut donner aux juges les moyens d'agir
parce que vous savez on parle des
fichiers s p les gens ne savent pas
toujours ce que c'est malheureusement c
fini par apprendre oui mais je le
rappelle régulièrement mais vous savez
comment on en est en flèche on peut être
écoutée à un moment parce que vous êtes
dans un réseau ceci ou cela et donc mais
on sait sur une écoute téléphonique
qu'on peut décider de vous mettre dans
une pizza donc c'est pas parce que
forcément vous avez participé un coup de
fil que vous êtes forcément
systématiquement donc en situation
d'être un dangereux terroriste donc il y
à un certain nombre de précautions à
prendre dans un état de droit c'est aux
juges leur souvent vous entendez nicolas
sarkozy parlait hier soir dans un
meeting à provins de peste noire
à propos de la menace terroriste qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire est-ce que lord
avec les ports n'est donc pas un meeting
moi même donc je vais la campagne pour
alain juppé donc se passe pas mon temps
c'est assez amusant on peut pas parler
avec les médias aujourd'hui vous avez
deux sets zéro panne
si on ne parle pas de nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy je le respecte c'est
quelqu'un de très bien mais moi je fais
la campagne de la jupe et donc tous les
soirs je fais des meetings pour alain
juppé je parle de la gravité de la
situation je parle de sa solidité je
parle de son projet et puis ma foi je ne
cherche pas à parler systématiquement de
nicolas sarkozy je pense que peste noire
ça rappelle des mauvaises périodes
donc ce sont pas forcément les mots très
pertinent mais bon je n'ai pas écouté le
discours dans le monde de ce week end je
crois michel serres qui est un
philosophe et de l'ordre et 86 ans dit
en substance on surestime le risque d'un
bon terroristes on vit quand même malgré
ce risque en temps de paix et quand on
quand on comptabilise au fond le nombre
de morts dus aux actes terroristes en
france et en europe
on en fait presque trop alors évidemment
je le caricature un peu mais c'est un
peu le sens de ce qu'il voulait dire
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
pas vraiment même si j'ai un profond
respect pour michel serres parce que ce
qui compte dans l'état de guerre c'est
la puissance de la menace et la menace
elle est réelle la menace elle est
partie fille ciel et beaucoup de gens
ont peur ils ont peur pour eux mêmes ils
ont peur pour leurs enfants
ils ont peur pour leur leurs amis ils
ont peur et donc ce qui caractérise un
état de guerre
c'est que nous avons un adversaire qui
il put l'horreur avec une gourmandise
pathologique qui nous effraie et donc
qui créé des troubles dans notre propre
société qui est vraiment significatif
d'un état de guerre
donc c'est vrai qu'on peut aller au
cinéma c'est vrai qu'on peut se promener
c'est vrai qu'on peut passer à travers
mais il n'empêche qu'il y a dans la
société une pesanteur
parce que c'est vrai que les menaces
sont jour et que quand on est informé
des renseignements qui sont aujourd'hui
à la disposition par exemple des
parlementaires il ya quand même des
menaces lourdes et sérieuses qui pèsent
sur la sécurité du pays je vais vous
apporter la preuve maintenant jean
pierre raffarin que les médias ne sont
pas les seuls à parler de nicolas
sarkozy on va écouter françois hollande
je ne laisserai pas la france est habile
et réduites voire ses libertés mises en
cause sont d'état de droit contesté sur
l'éducation réduite et sa culture aux
et c'est le combat d'une vie
est ce que nicolas sarkozy est un danger
pour notre état de droit
mais ce que très claire dans ce qu'on
vient d'entendre là c'est qu'au fond le
président de la république
il rêve d'une chose d'un match avec
nicolas sarkozy il veut rejouer le match
de 2012 et au fond qui dans le pays a
envie qu'on rejoue le match
sarkozy hollande ce match était le match
de 2012
ce n'est pas le match de 2010 est donc
moi ce que je note ici et pour bien
connaître les uns et les autres c'est
qu'au fond françois hollande craint
alain juppé et que choisit son
concurrent préféré est choisi nicolas
sarkozy et puis donc il ya une sorte de
dialectique on avait déjà vu ça à propos
du congrès vous vous souvenez quand il
s'agissait de la déchéance de
nationalité on avait vu que nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande avait des
positions assez voisines ce que je crois
c'est que la gauche aujourd'hui a de
fortes probabilités de ne pas être au
second tour le président de la
république affaiblie sur sa droite par
macron affaibli sur sa gauche par
montebourg a peu de chances d'être au
second tour
donc ceux qui nous écoutent là ils
doivent bien ça
le match de la présidentielle au mois de
mai va se jouer en novembre quel match
préférez-vous le pen juppé ou le pen
sarkozy
j'ai choisi moi je préfère confier à
alain juppé ce combat contre la dame le
pen
dernière question dernière question on
passe un peu à la matière économique
budgétaire
on voit que en ce moment tous les
candidats à la primaire à droite sont en
train de lâcher la un peu la bride sur
le déficit et notamment françois fillon
qui est prêt qui parle maintenant d'un
déficit au dessus de 4 et demi pour cent
du pub en 2017 est ce que est ce que
alain juppé et vous vous inquiétiez
votre votre candidat est ce que vous
garantissez que vous ne dépasserait pas
les 3% de déficit
c'est vraiment un objectif c'est
vraiment un objectif très important il
faut dégager les marges de manoeuvre
pour nos priorités on parlera tout à
l'heure de défense on parlera on peut
pas dire aujourd'hui qu'on est en guerre
et laisser nos armées sans les budgets
qui sont nécessaires donc il est
nécessaire de faire des économies de
diminuer la dépense publique pour
infecter un certain nombre de dépenses
sur des priorités et donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment te donner ce cap des 3 %
et puis quand on est européen ces règles
on l'a défini ensemble il faut assumer
ce qu'on a défini ensemble et donc là la
parole vis-à-vis de l'europe
c'est quelque chose qui compte pour eux
pas question de les renégocier non je
pensais moi j'aurais eu l'occasion de le
faire discuter avec l'union européenne
je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans l'état de
crise de l'europe il faut que la france
soit digne d'être un bon élève de
l'europe est de faire en sorte que la
les économies budgétaires qui sont quand
même non pas l'intérêt de l'europe
mais l'intérêt des français soit dans
notre non pas de deyrolle magique
déployer leur a pas de dérapage
merci monsieur raffin merci beaucoup
jean-francis pécresse et maintenant
c'est nadège peljak de l' agence france
presse qui nous rejoint monsieur
raffarin votre ma question ah bah vous
allez vos courbes en vouloir parce que
je vous parlais de monsieur sarkozy
réprouve autre chose et je c pas grave
c'est pas grave alors on y va
alain juppé donc vous le soutenez on a
bien compris est ce qu'il va tenir la
distance face à nicolas sarkozy
évidemment évidemment parce que
aujourd'hui
seulement il est en tête dans les
sondages il est déterminé mais ça devait
être quelque chose un coup de tonnerre
que l'entrée en campagne de nouveaux
candidats
il est évident qu'à partir du moment où
le panel s'élargit il ya des
effritements ici ou là je pense qu'il
est en tête qu'il est durablement en
tête je pense qu'il est très déterminé
il est très serein et je peux vous dire
que moi je suis très confiant je vois
aujourd'hui la campagne se dérouler de
manière très positive
alors je veux revenir sur ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure à mon confrère
jean francis pécresse
vous parliez de stratégie de
rassemblement à vous disiez je préfère
la stratégie de rassemblement
sous entendu celles de monsieur juppé à
la stratégie de combat sous entendu
celles de clivage de clivage vous avez
dit addictives à j'ai compris de combat
doivent quelque fois un peu alors deux
climats de toute façon ça n'a pas
d'importance à ne change rien à mes
questions
vous dites il faut rassembler les
français certes pour 2017
mais là on est à la primaire 2016 il
s'agit de rassembler les français de
droite à ces primaires c'est le français
de droite qui vont aller voter monsieur
raffarin s'est pas assez pas les
français de gauche mais bien sûr que
d'abord les français de gauche en a plus
beaucoup
oui mais enfin regarder dans lé jour là
dans les législatives devaient les
partiels il aurait était peu présent il
ya des gens qui ont la conscience ce
gaucher des gens qui ont voté hollande a
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'électeurs du parti social alors revenu
à ma question alors comment on fait pour
rassembler les français langue d'abord
je vais je vais vous êtes de droite
alors justement ça c'est très important
il faut penser à la première étape mais
on ne fait pas des primaires pour les
primaires ont fait les primaires pour
choisir un président de la république
donc on pense naturellement à la
situation dans laquelle on va se
retrouver au 4e tour c'est-à-dire au
deuxième tour des présidentielles
si vous demandez aux français de
réfléchir quel est le meilleur candidat
pour redress pliké nommé même nom mais
je vais vous dire c'est très simple
est-ce qui est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut redresser la france
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
redonner de la sécurité aux français
est-ce que vous pensez que face à la
gravité de la situation il faut mettre
de la solidité dans la politique
français si vous pensez ça vous devez
choisir le meilleur candidat au premier
tour le meilleur candidat au premier
tour de la primaire
ce n'est pas le meilleur candidat
électorale ce n'est pas le plus tapageur
ce n'est pas le plus agité ce n'est pas
celui qui va faire le plus de voix et
vas-y non non non mais pas du tout de ne
pas du tout je dis comme ça je prends
mais peut-être mais c'est pas comme ça
je le dis moi je dis simplement voilà le
avec eux que je vote pour le plus serein
le plus calme celui qui va pouvoir
rassembler et si je vais aux primaires
ce n'est pas pour les primaires ce n'est
pas un match dans l'est républicain
il s'agit pas de savoir quel est le
meilleur républicain il ne s'agit pas de
savoir quel est le celui qui aujourd'hui
doit porter les couleurs du des
républicains il s'agit de choisir le
président pour les français pourquoi
faisons nous des primaires c'est pas
dans notre culture
le général de gaulle ne nous a pas
appris à faire des primaires pourquoi
faisons nous des primaires parce que
madame le pen est à 25 ou 30%
c'est à dire que madame le pen elle est
sans doute au second tour et que si nous
nous avons deux candidats
nous serons comme lionel jospin en 2002
nous serons absent du second tour n'y a
pas besoin de vous et de deux candidats
menno meyjes une tour en 2017 avait si
on n'avait pas de prix mais à je vous
dis ah si vous ne voulez je vous dis je
vous explique pourquoi nous on fait des
primaires
nous avons fait des primaires pour avoir
un candidat contre madame le pen car
avec des primaires nous mettons notre
candidat à 25-30 % c'est-à-dire qu'il
est qualifié au second tour si nous
avions une candidature juppé par une
candidature sarkozy tous les deux
seraient éliminés comme il ya eu la
candidature je soutiens la candidature
chevènement lacaunais tueur taubira qui
fait que monsieur jospin en 2002 a été
lu nous voulons éviter l'élimination
donc si nous avons fait une primaire ce
n'est pas pour désigner notre champion
pour que les républicains est un
champion c'est pour désigner celui qui
va battre madame le pen au deuxième tour
de la présidentielle
c'est pour ça que nous faisons des
primaires et de ce point de vue là
beaucoup de gens vont venir voter
d'où la salle appel aux conduits au aux
électeurs justement jour qui évoque
directement pour monsieur juppé dans le
cas de figure que vous ne dites pour
qu'ils soient les délais clairs et les
clairanencs la lorraine je lance un
appel à tous ceux qui ont un attachement
à la république à tous ceux qui
partagent un projet d'alternance qui
veulent signer la charte de nos valeurs
je les invite à venir vous dire qu'ils
aient voté hollande qu'ils aient voté
sarkozy qu'ils aient voté x qu'ils aient
voté y maintenant il s'agit de parler
d'eux
venir pour l'avenir quel est le meilleur
candidat que nous allons mettre
probablement face à madame le pen c'est
simple je vous écoute on a l'impression
que la gauche on n'en parle plus de ça
ce ne sera pas au second tour
prudence prudence mais regardez regardez
les élections législatives vous a vu
très souvent regardé les élections
régionales ronde à gauche il nous a pas
échappé qu'il avait pas de socialistes
dans la région nord aujourd'hui que les
socialistes avaient été éliminé aux
régionales il compris dans région paca
donc voyez bien qu'en même temps il ya
eu des problèmes électoraux et c'était
avant l'effondrement de monsieur
hollande donc monsieur macron il peut
être candidat mais s'il est hors des
primaires il sera marginalisé vous
faites s'il est dans la mer mais la cote
moi je n'ai peur de personne je pense
que les gens intelligents qui peuvent
aider le pays
ça peut toujours être utile j'y reviens
je suis pas un polémiste je ne suis pas
je respecte les personnes donc il peut
il veut servir unis c'est très bien mais
ce que je dis c'est qu'il va avoir
beaucoup de mal parce que où il est
candidat dans la primaire et à ce moment
là et là c'est un nom à mon avis
beaucoup de difficultés ou s'il n'est
pas dans le candidat à la primaire il
est candidat m'amener à la presse
ce sera difficile donc je pense que il a
sans doute un avenir mais que c'est pas
pour le printemps 2010 m c'est mon
sentiment à propos je vois le dossier
alsthom
je dis qu'il aurait mieux fait de s'en
occuper plutôt que de penser à sa
compagne devront tout à l'heure à propos
des primaires je vous lance est
quasiment un appel aux électeurs de
gauche qui peuvent se reconnaître dans
les valeurs jugées parfois vous dites de
grand atout là tous les lecteurs de
français volants mais tous ces électeurs
qui ont quitté la gauche d'accord le pô
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que la
gauche n'a plus suffisamment d'électeurs
est rien et on le voit quand vous voyez
que dans ces élections législatives la
gauche disparaît du ce bâtiment comme
une présidentielle c'est c'est différent
on a l'impression que chacun rentre dans
sa jeunesse mais écoute puis peut-être
monsieur jospin il a été présent en 2012
second tour
monsieur jospin c'est monsieur le pen
qui était présent et vous croyez que
madame le pen n'a pas progressé par
rapport à son père et moi je crois que
les électeurs de gauche s'en souviennent
et l'instant c'est pour ça qu'ils
rentrent dans leur case peuvent
peut-être qu'ils peuvent rentrer dans
leurs cases mais à ce moment là il faut
le dire à monsieur montebourg qui rend
dans la même case de monsieur macro qui
rendent à la même plage de monsieur
hollande quand ça fait beaucoup de
maires alors grâce à fait beaucoup de
canal
mrd leurs primes areva propos de votre
primaire jean pierre raffarin vous allez
nous dire après coup après avoir écouté
nicolas sarkozy si vous avez des
inquiets sur le déroulé de la
compétition et de l'alberta est de plus
en plus aiguisée car nicolas sarkozy
avait dit ceci l'autre jour je ne parle
pas d'un code de bonne conduite je
n'aime pas le code de bonne conduite
j'aime la bonne conduite
et quand ils font un code sait déjà
qu'on est dans le problème c'est un peu
rapide un propos de tribunes moi je suis
pour un code de bonne conduite soit une
différence de plus moi pour moi un code
de bonne conduite c'est d'abord
l'égalité entre les candidats qui n'est
pas un qui se sert des moyens du parti
plus que les autres que c'est tout ça à
la qualité qu'il ya une transparence et
donc déduit et puis surtout une éthique
des primaires et donc les tic des
primaires c'est quoi c'est qu'on
soutienne celui qui arrive naturellement
en tête et donc que l'on soit tous
rassemblés ensuite pour celui qui est
primaire or on dit ça c'est l'éthique
des primaires et de ce point de vue là
je ne suis pas pour attaquer les autres
c'est normal que nicolas sarkozy dise ce
qu'il a envie de dire c'est son droit
il se trouve que là je ne suis pas
d'accord mais je ne l'attaquent temps
alors nous on parle de nicolas sarkozy
d'alain juppé enfin il ya les autres
quand même qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent
et pourquoi ce serait pas monsieur
fillon ou bruno le maire ou jean
françois copé ou nathalie kosciusko
morizet s'il ya quand même une femme
dans votre frimaire enfin vous avez
oublier monsieur mariton noms qui
sortent dans le pourtant aimé mérite
tout à fait excusable
voilà bien écoutez moi je pense que tous
ces candidats
d'abord ils élargissent l'appel à la
population il les avait la base
électorale pour nos primaires et nous
avons une ambition qui est d'avoir au
moins trois millions de votants donc il
est important qu'il y ait des gens ayant
fait en plus monsieur juppé aura une
chance
on verra plus horrible couvrir oui on
lit ça mais plus il y aura de votants
plus la primaire sera crédible forte et
entraînera le pays donc moi je pense
qu'il faut une primaire qui dépasse les
trois millions et de ce point de vue là
qu'on soit nombreux à faire campagne a
expliqué pourquoi il faut voter au fond
va dire aux gens la présidentielle elle
peut pas se passer de vous mais
attention car peut-être que tout va se
régler à la primaire
hesher le gagnant de la primaire stora
le futur président de l'hôtel c'est pas
sûr mais peut-être et je dis aux gens ne
laissez pas passer ce tour-là si vous
avez des convictions du centre de non
inscrits au coeur des valeurs de la
république
laissez pas passer n'est pas de la 3c de
tous non parce que je vais au-delà
non non parce que la droite il est
évident qu'à droite on l'appelle il est
évident que la droite et le centre
mais on va au delà tous ceux qui veulent
participer à ces élections peuvent
participer à ces élections c'est libre
c'est pratiquement gratuit ces deux
euros essais libres c'est à dire qu'on
ne demande pas la carte du parti donc
tout le monde peut y participer
donc moi je souhaite une large
participation est de ce point de vue là
nathalie kosciusko par exemple vous avez
raison de souligner le problème de la
présence féminine
je pense qu'elle élargit la base
politique de la primaire et c'est rare
et c'est une rallier évidente du second
tour pour le pensait le second tour je
suis très prudent je ne sais pas comment
les choses se passeront il y aura des
négociations donc il faut alors les
enfants qui sait qu'il rejoindra
monsieur juppé au deuxième tour pardon
michel des alternants frère je ne le
sais pas et vous savez quand on est
candidat
là je suis pas une petite ysaline sa
devise a dit françois fillon
ça se met à faire françois de sales au
zaman qui sera peut-être je dis bien
avoir échappé je suis en campagne
électorale pour alain juppé comme vacher
le rôle pour alain juppé alors on verra
après pour les autres mais pour vous
c'est mon cas on verra au deuxième tour
mais pour le moment
ne me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
envie de dire c'est à dire moi je suis
là alors parlé d'un typique on verra il
y aura peut-être des surprises au soir
du premier tour de cette primaire alors
une question que nous sommes si vous
deviez qualifié la principale qualité et
de monsieur juppé et puis ensuite de
monsieur sarkozy encore sarkozy où iriez
quoi la principale qualité de monsieur
juppé ce la solidité et de nicolas
sarkozy c'est l'énergie est leur
principal défaut je pense que nicolas
sarkozy gelé plutôt dans une logique de
clivages c'est 5 je trouve que c'est pas
c'est pas idéal
et puis alain juppé ma foi
j'ai du mal à lui trouver quelques
défauts je vais en chercher je vais
merci beaucoup nadège bon la troisième
partie vous de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant avec michaël szames s2 public
sénat qu'hier il va on attend beaucoup
ça craque de partout l'armée est à bout
de souffle c'est le cas je ne dirais pas
cela c'est un peu excessif l'armée sous
une grande tension est aujourd'hui
toutes nos forces projetable sont
projetés et qu'il est aujourd'hui très
difficile par exemple d'engager une
nouvelle opération sans se désengager
d'une autre donc je pense que nous
sommes au taquet et il est important de
revoir par exemple opération sentinel
lui met un peu de flexibilité
je pense qu'il y avait un certain
brouhaha veut dire quoi monsieur ça veut
dire qu'on repart mais des postes
ça veut dire qu'on peut pas non
mobiliser des gens aussi longtemps dans
des conditions si difficiles quand vous
envoyez pendant huit semaines sur des
lits de camp dans les casernes à paris
des jeunes qui viennent de province que
vous le dire à signer un peu de leur
famille tout ceci est quelquefois pour
faire des gardes statiques
il ya sans doute une utilisation plus
rationnelle plus efficace de ce soutien
de la défense qui est très important à
la sécurité du pays
mais ça doit être aménagé donc il y a là
des réflexions qu'ils sont engagés
l'université d'été de la défense a
évoqué tous ces sujets la semaine
dernière je pense qu'il ya un certain
nombre de progrès à faire
françois hollande l'avait on avait parlé
ils voulaient réduire le nombre de
personnels sur une opération sentinel
avant les menaces d'attentât et avant
les attentats notamment pour
l'assassinât du prêtre roux france et
finalement des revenus à plus de 7000
hommes sur le terrain je pense que vous
avez à combien aujourd'hui le nombre de
personnels nécessaires sur le terrain
je pense qu'il faut pouvoir monter à 10
milles mais il faut pouvoir en période
où les menaces sont moins fortes pouvoir
redescendre significativement notamment
à 7 mai donc dakhla question très
importante aujourd'hui c'est la question
de notre budget les capacités comme
qu'on peut y avoir donc d'où la
nécessité pour répondre tout à l'heure
la question du déficit budgété de 2 de
faire des efforts partout pour pouvoir
monter le plus vite possible à un budget
de 2 % dû faire l'objet d'un consensus
je vois droite gauche on n'est pas
encore tous d'accord sur la date à
laquelle on n'a rien
petit tous d'accord dans les
propositions à droite avec nicolas
sarkozy et quelques autres donc il y a
je pense vraiment un travail qui est
important à faire pour soutenir notre
défense
non seulement la défense c'est pour
notre sécurité est essentielle mais
aussi c'est essentiel aujourd'hui pour
l'innovation et notre politique
industrielle
nous avons aujourd'hui une industrie de
la défense qui est remarquable et nous
avons une responsabilité nouvelle
maintenant que les britanniques ont
quitté l'europe continentale l'europe
qui assure en première ligne qui a la
plus grande armée capable de se projeter
extérieur c'est la france une toute
dernière question puisque avec michael
vous parliez des conflits qui envoie sur
les routes les flots de réfugiés que
l'on connaît le ministre de l'intérieur
on le sait veut supprimer la jungle de
calais et répartir douze mille réfugiés
un peu partout en france est-ce que vous
soutenez ce plan mis en oeuvre par les
préfets alors que vous nous aviez dit
ici même il ya quelques mois qu'il
faille que effectivement les villages de
france accueille lé là on est on est sur
des sujets très différents que là il
s'agit de gens qui doivent aller en
angleterre il s'agit pas des gens qui
cherchent leur intégration en france
donc ces gens là il faut faire en sorte
que ce soit ils retournent chez eux soit
qu'ils aillent en angleterre c'est pas
notre sujet donc je suis vraiment pour
que l'on puisse rediscuter et les
accords du touquet mais les positions
qui ont été prises sur ces sujets là il
ne s'agit pas d'accueillir des gens qui
veulent venir en france il s'agit des
gens qui veulent passer en france donc
où on les arrête avant où on les laisse
passer après mais on peut pas se trouver
ici en charge de la gestion de ce
problème qui ne nous concerne pas en
direct même si naturellement on est très
sensible à la condition de ces gens là
et qu'il faut rendre cette condition la
plus humaine possible
merci jean pierre raffarin merci mais
quelle merci à tous
on se retrouve donc la semaine prochaine
pour le numéro deux de l'épreuve de
vérité notre invité sera jean christophe
cambadélis le premier secrétaire du ps
très bonne soirée
vos rendez vous avec public sénat
territoire d'infos c'est votre rendez
vous quotidiens d'information tourner
vers les territoires série vigué reçoit
invités politiques et journalistes de la
pqr pour décrypter et analyser
l'actualité qui vous concerne territoire
d'un fonds du lundi au vendredi à 7
heures 30 en direct sur public sénat et
sud radio
bienvenue à bibliothèque médicis dans le
geste de d'écriture y avait à la fois le
désir de sauver ce qui s'était passé et
aussi le souhait des cuisez cette
histoire est de transformer cette âme un
motif littéraire je m'en vais dit louis
xiv mais du temps demeurera toujours est
il le dit dans un souffle
oui selena ses dernières paroles voilà
les filmera toujours il n'a jamais dit
l'état c'est moi je pense qu papillon
que vous simplifier un peu et que celle
ci a été reçue c'est déjà pas mal
bibliothèque médicis vendredi à 22h sur
public sénat vous connaissez les plus
célèbres le csa la cnil ou encore la mf
qui régule les marchés financiers en
france
tous ces organismes sont ce qu'on
appelle des autorités administratives
indépendantes des aai il en est créé une
parle il est bien évident que cela n'est
pas raisonnable
depuis plusieurs années l'état s'est
désengagé de secteurs stratégiques au
profit de ces autorités
cette un délitement de l'état
ce n'est pas raisonnable parce que cela
a un coût mais vous allez découvrir que
pour certaines d'entre elles il y à des
dérives
c'est un objet juridique non identifié
senna en action demain à 18h30 sur
public sénat on évoque souvent la figure
des patrons du cac 40 quand on parle des
entreprises mais qu'en est il des
petites affaires familiales forte de
quelques salariés d'un petit patron trop
souvent seuls face aux tracasseries et
aux difficultés de survie des petites et
moyennes entreprises en cas de faillite
c'est souvent la dépression le
déclassement voire parfois le suicide
les petits patrons dans l'apurement
c'est le documentaire et le débat d'un
monde en doc un monde en doc samedi à
22h sur public sénat public sénat
au coeur du débat ça vous regarde
présentée par arnaud ardoin dans un
instant un documentaire pour s'informer
un débat pour mieux comprendre retrouver
chaque soir député témoins et experts
pour décrypter les réalités historiques
sociales ou politiques de notre société
droit de suite présenté par jean-pierre
gratien ce soir à minuit et demi